so bioinformatics for infectious
diseases
is really a program designed to address
the pressing need to understand
characterize Monitor and address by
intervention the infectious diseases
that are so prevalent and are
characterizing this 21st or 20 yeah 21st
century so in this program we'll talk
about how to apply data analysis tools
and a lot of them are going to be
somewhat similar to each other but
applied in very different types of
outbreaks epidemics coronavirus Ebola
virus rhinovirus tuberculosis malaria so
different types of viral bacterial and
other pathogenic diseases
the program is really designed in a
similar fashion uh you will explore
relevant topics tools methods data
repositories project examples and you'll
be able to see how multi-omics analysis
analysis of genomic transcriptomic
proteomic data is going to inform
different types of decisions about
outbreaks before we jump into this let's
briefly talk about what is the
definition of infectious diseases so
infectious diseases also called
communicable diseases are called by a
pathogen and that pathogen can be a
bacteria virus parasite or fungi and
these kinds of diseases are different
from non-infectious diseases or what's
commonly known as chronic diseases and
so we will actually talk about specific
applications of bioinformatics to the
study of infectious diseases